[Musique]
la salle des pas perdus
c'est là où tout commence où tous se
croisent justiciables avocat personnel
plus de 400 personnes d'habitude et
quasiment aucune aujourd'hui
justiciables y en a peut-être 30 - 10 je
dirais et les avocats il y en a pas
beaucoup non plus et du personnel
judiciaire me lie à entre 20 et 40
personnes selon les jours 80 à 90 % de
notre activité juridictionnelle habituel
a a diminué
la règle c'est de ne traiter que les
contentieux essentiels et urgents pour
comprendre ce que cela signifie
direction le monde du pénal et première
halte dans une salle où a lieu une
audience de comparution immédiate
c'est une audience une des audiences qui
est maintenue qui va être jugé tout tout
de suite
c'était des faits de violences contre sa
compagne
donc ça fait partie des urgences puisque
les violences intrafamiliales reste des
dossiers qui sont considérées comme
urgentes
un peu plus loin un autre lieu continue
à vivre la permanence pénale du parquet
qui gère toutes les gardes à vues ici en
temps normal jusqu'à 80 appels sont
reçus chaque jour
aujourd'hui c'est quelques-uns la
délinquance a baissé et peu de personnes
en garde à vue sont convoqués on essaye
de limiter les présentations et les
affaires qui passent en comparution
immédiate vraiment au strict minimum
parce que on a aussi le souci d'éviter
l'incarcération puisque on a aussi
associé de régulation la population
carcérale mais les affaires qui méritent
d'être traités ce qui sont les plus
graves
le son de la même façon qu'elles
l'étaient avant le confinement le numéro
de dossier
direction ensuite les affaires civiles
où l'on règle les contentieux de la vie
courante dette succession contrat et
cetera ce matin 42 dossiers sont à
l'étude
j'ai vu les policiers qu'on peut retenir
son audio en fait je suis arrivé au
manque de 6,6 sont donc garder mais pour
aller plus vite
ils ne passeront pas par la salle
d'audience mercredi matin c'est une
véritable ruche puisqu'il y a entre 30
et 50 avocats qui sont en étant plus
quelques particuliers et c'était assez
étrange de voir cette salle d'audience
mercredi matin à vide
sans audience les décisions sont
désormais prises sur papier entre juges
et avocats
c'est le cas dans beaucoup de services
celui de la justice des mineurs
notamment commence à avoir le réflexe
ici on s'occupe des enfants auteurs de
délits ou plus souvent ceux qui sont
victimes de violences nous sommes quatre
juges des enfants en côte d'or et nous
passons toutes les matinées chacun du le
temps du temps en audience pour entendre
les parents les enfants les avocats mais
depuis deux mois un seul juge assure la
permanence
c'est un travail qui est fait sur
dossier ce qui est une forme de de
souffrance pour le magistrat qui a
choisi d'être juge des enfants puisque
l'intérêt du métier et puis l'intérêt
aussi pour les justiciables cette foire
s'exprimer de pouvoir rencontrer un juge
de pouvoir dire leur colère leur
tristesse de pouvoir les pour les
enfants à s'exprimer et être entendu par
un juge et pour un juge comprendre un
dossier c'est se laisser un peu porté
aussi par l'émotion qui ressort d'une
audience
la justice a donc dû laisser de côté ses
états d'âme est restée positive
ça nous oblige nécessairement à repenser
nos organisations et peut-être on
l'espère à à la fin arriver à les
organisations qui seront peut-être
meilleur le télétravail les visio
réunion les documents numérisés
les pistes sont nombreuses et urgente
par tout ça craque
en deux mois le retard s'est accumulé et
les délais d'examen ne cesse de
s'allonger